SIX ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING WE HAVE TWENTY
SEVEN BILLS TO CONSIDER TODAY
NOTING THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
WILL GO AHEAD AND START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND I SEE MISS GROVE
THE AUDIENCE.
MS GRAHAM YOU BE PRESENT SB TWO
TWO FORD ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SOON AS WE GET A
QUORUM HERE.
GOOD MORNING WELL THAT'S PRETTY
LOUD GOOD MORNING SB TWO TO FOUR
MAKES AGRICULTURE AFFECT A
SEPARATE CRIME AND DIRECTS FINDS.
AND AS ASSESSED AS RESULT A
CONVICTION OF THAT CRIME BACK TO
EXISTING CRIME PREVENTION
PROGRAMS.
COUNTY THAT PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM OUR FRESNO
KINGS MADERA KERN MERCED
MONTEREY SAMBHAJI NO SAND BUT
SANTA BARBARA SANTA CRUZ SAN
JOAQUIN SAN LUIS OBISPO AND
STANISLAUS.
AGRICULTURE THEFT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY -- IS BEEN EXT AND ON THE
COAST HAS BEEN EXTREMELY --
MODERNIZE WITH CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
IN A LOT OF HIGH VALUE DOLLAR
ITEMS TO DISAPPEAR WHICH STEALS
ACTUAL FOOD OFF THE TABLE FOR
CONSTITUENTS AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE SEPARATE OUT
THESE CLIMB SO LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAN OPERATE TOGETHER.
AND TRAXXAS TO STICKS AND BRING
THOSE FINES BACK TO THE RURAL
AREAS THAT CAN HELP STOP CRIME
FROM AGRICULTURE AGRICULTURE
WITH THAT AND I WOULD APPRECIATE
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
THE SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE REGIONAL
MEASURE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE A WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME -- THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL DECIDED TO SPIN
A FISCAL IMPACT RESULTING FROM
THIS BILL ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL'S UNLIKELY TO HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE COUNTY JAIL
POPULATION OR THE STATE PRISON
POPLATION BECAUSE GRANT THAT
DOES ALREADY PUNISHABLE BY
IMPRISONMENT IN THE COUNTY JAIL
NOT EXCEEDING ONE YEAR.
FINANCE NOTES THIS BILL MAKE
CALLS LOCAL AGENCIES AND SPECIFY
COUNTIES TO LOSE REVENUES TO THE
EXTENT THAT IT RETRACTS BE FINE
FOR THE AFTER AGRICULTURE
EQUIPMENT.
WE FROM CITY OR COUNTY FUNDS FOR
THE PROGRAM SPECIFIED IN THE
BILL HOWEVER BECAUSE THESE ARE
VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS AND THE BILL
DOES NOT REQUIRE PARTICIPATION
IT WOULD NOT CONSTITUTE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS.
IN NINETEEN WITH JACK CLOSE I
WOULD JUST REQUESTED I'VE IT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE'LL TAKE
IT UP SINCE WE GET A QUORUM
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I THINK MR MINING WAS NEXT.
MISTER MONEY OF SB FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN IT ENJOYS IT YOU PASS
RECOMMENDATION AS SOON AS WE GET
A QUORUM.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- REAL BRIEFLY SENATE
BILL.
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN HAS BEEN
ORGANIZED BY STUDENTS FROM CAL
POLY ACROSS THE STATE.
AS A NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS IN FOOD
IN SECURITY CONTINUES TO RISE.
THE CSU AND YOU SEE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS WITH
ACCURATE ESTIMATES FOR THE COST
OF ATTENDING THEIR SCHOOLS.
THE BILL FOR SIXTY SEVEN
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY IN REQUEST UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. TO PLACE ON THEIR
WEBSITES THE CONFERENCE OF COST
OF ATTENDANCE INCLUDING THE
CURRENT COST OF AN OFF CAMPUS
TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT IN A
SINGLE BEDROOM IN A PRIVATE HOME.
FOR PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS THIS
BILL EMPOWERS PERSPECTIVE
STUDENTS TO MAKE FINANCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE DECISIONS.
REVIEWING A PERSPECTIVE CSU OR
YOU SEE I ALSO WANT TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUT CHIU ASIDE
JEAN.
WHO'S BEEN WORKING WITH THE
STUDENTS WHO.
I BROUGHT THIS BILL TO THE FLOOR
TO ALL OF YOU SO AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME YOUR QUESTION I
BOTH.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
FINANCE IS NOT HAVE A POSITION
ON THIS BILL BOTH OF YOU SEE AND
THE CSU ESTIMATE MINOR AND
AFFORDABLE COST.
THANK YOU -- STILL SEEN A LACK
REQUIRE MUCH LIKE CLOSE.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME WOULD
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS.
CENTRE BELL SB TWO EIGHTY FORUMS
GAVE YOU THE WRONG INFORMATION
THE WHOLE WAY I THOUGHT YOU HAD
NOTHING UP.
SO I ASSUME YOU'RE GOING -- TO
WAVE THE SUSPENSE ITEMS.
AND I SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AS SOON
AS WE GET A QUORUM -- THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING -- SB -- TWO EIGHTY
FOUR IS THE KEEP BILLS YOU'VE
CLOSE TO HOME ACT -- CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND USE.
IN VARIOUS DETENTION FACILITIES
IN APPROXIMATELY. SEVEN HUNDRED
ARE CONFINED IN THE STATE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE.
AND SOME COUNTIES -- JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEMS.
ARE STRUCTURED DIFFERENTLY THAT
THEY DON'T USE THE STATE'S
SYSTEM AT ALL.
AND THERE ARE SEVENTEEN CONTENT
IS MANY WITH SMALL POPULATIONS.
THAT CURRENTLY SEND ZERO YOU'VE
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN
NINETEEN COUNTIES IT'S AN FIVE
OR FEWER SO -- IS A SUBSET OF
THE COUNTIES THAT ACTUALLY SENT.
KIDS TO THE DEPARTMENT.
THE ANNUAL COST -- IS ABOUT. FOR
THE STATE IS ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER USE.
AND COUNTIES CONTRIBUTE 8% OR
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND TO THE
STATE WITH THE STATE PAYING THE
REST OF THE COST.
AND THE LOS STATE FEES IS
ACTUALLY KIND OF AN INCENTIVE
FOR SOME OF THE COUNTY SAN
YOU'VE.
VERSUS -- LOOKING AT THEIR OWN
REHABILITATION SYSTEMS. TO GROW
AND CREATING THE BILL. FOR A
SUBSET OF THE USE OF LET US THE
LESS -- VIOLENCE -- VIEW -- WE
HAVE -- THE BILL ACTUALLY RAISES
THE CONTRIBUTION TO OUR TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR TO
SERVE AS AN INCENTIVE. FOR THEM
NOT TO SEND -- THOSE KIND THAT
SUBGROUP OF OF YOUNG PEOPLE TO
THE STATE.
AND WITHOUT STATE ACTION SOME
KINDS WILL CONTINUE RELY HEAVILY
ON THE STATE'S.
SO WE WANT THEM TO INVEST IN
ALTERNATIVES AND COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS -- TO KEEP OF YOUTH
CLOSER TO THE FAMILIES.
AND THIS WILL ACTUALLY RESULT IN
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS BECAUSE IT
IS TO THE STATE.
AS WELL AS COST SAVINGS FROM THE
REDUCTION OF RECIDIVISM.
AND FUTURE INCARCERATION WE OF
WITNESSES.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE START WHEN
IT SAYS IT'S IF IT'S OKAY I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY.
GONZALEZ PRESENT BIGELOW BLOOM.
BONTA BROUGH CALDERON.
CARRILLO.
CHAU.
DEEP.
EGGMAN FONG.
GABRIEL.
GARCIA MISSION.
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK HERE RIVAS.
THANK YOU WE NOW HAVE A
COMMITTEE AT CORMAN WERE IN
COMMITTEE -- SPEAKERS AND
SUPPORT IF YOU HAVE A TWO
MINUTES AND SPEAK TO FINANCES
ONLY.
GOOD MORNING BRIAN GOLDSTINE
WITH THE CENTER ON JUVENILE AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
ALTHOUGH JUNE JUSTICE SYSTEMS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE SHRINKING
RAPIDLY DJ CONTINUES TO OPERATE
THREE LARGE FACILITIES AND A
CAMP.
AT GREAT COST TO THE STATE.
AND STATE TAXPAYERS THEIR
DIFFERING MOST OF THE BILL FOR
THE SINK MOSTLY MALE SPENCER
SYSTEM.
THE CURRENT FEE FOR COMMITTING
YOUTH TO DJJ.
IS TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YOUTH WHICH REPRESENTS JUST
80% OF THE TOTAL COST OF THE
STATE SYSTEM.
WHICH EXCEEDS THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR.
IT'S NOT LESS EXPENSIVE FOR
COUNTIES TO PAY THIS FEE.
THEN TO PROVIDE SERVICES LOCALLY.
THIS CREATES A PROBLEMATIC
INCENTIVE. TO SEND YOUTH FOR
STATE INSTITUTIONS.
ALTHOUGH MANY COUNTIES SEND FEW
OR NO YOUTH TO DJJ INCLUDING
MOST SMALL TOWNS.
SEVERAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
HEAVILY RELIANT ON THE STATE
SYSTEM AND ARE FAILING TO PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE.
BY INCREASING THE FEE TO
APPROXIMATELY 40% OF THE TRUE
COST.
SB TWO EIGHTY FOUR PROVIDES AN
IMPORTANT DISINCENTIVE. FOR
COUNTIES TO SEND YOUTH TO THESE
FAR FROM HOME INSTITUTIONS.
AND PROMOTES LOCAL
REHABILITATION.
WHICH RESEARCH EXPERIENCE AND
HISTORY SHOWS US IS MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE. FOR THE STATE SB
TWENTY FOUR WILL RESULT IN A
REVENUE INCREASE.
AND COST SAVINGS IN THE LOW TENS
OF MILLIONS.
WITH EVEN GREATER SAVINGS MADE
AVAILABLE IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS.
THE PRECISE FISCAL IMPACT OF THE
BILL WILL DEPEND ON HOW COUNTIES
RESPOND TO THIS DISINCENTIVE.
AND WHETHER THEY CHOOSE TO
MAXIMIZE THE USE OF EXISTING
STATE FUNDING. TO SERVE YOU'VE
CLOSER TO HOME.
COUNTIES YOU HAVING SEX MANY
SMALL TOWNS.
WILL RECEIVE SUBSTANTIAL SUPPORT
FROM THE STATE.
AND IT'S FOR THESE REASONS THAT
WE ASK FOR YOUR IDOL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION ON
BUT AFTER QUIRK IN A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO IS SECOND WITNESS
IN KEEP THAT TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
I'M GOOD MORNING CAM GO WITH
THESE JUSTICE COALITION -- IT'S
AN HONOR TO SPEAK TO TODAY ABOUT
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY FOR THE
CLOSE TO HOME ACT.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF FIVE CO
SPONSOR GROUPS EACH SERVING
YOUTH IMPACTED BY THE SYSTEM THE
CENTER ON JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE THE YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION.
MILBERG COURAGE AND COMMUNITY
WORKS.
TOGETHER WE REPRESENT MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED YEARS WORKING WITH
INCARCERATED YOUTH.
I AM ALSO HEAR SOMEONE WHO
BENEFITED BY BEING KEPT IN
COUNTY BECAUSE CITY ONE RESIDENT
INCARCERATED AS A YOUNG PERSON.
WELL I KNOW THE TREATMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL SHOULD HAVE BEEN
BETTER.
I BENEFITTED MOST FROM THE KEY
COMPONENT OF RECOVERY FOR USE IN
THE SYSTEM.
THE ABILITY TO REMAIN CLOSE TO
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY TO HAVE
FAMILY VISITS AND TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE CARED ABOUT US WE'RE
WITNESSING OUR TREATMENT.
AND ADVOCATING FOR OUR SAFETY
AND CARE.
AS A GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS
ANNOUNCED A MOVE OF THE JUVENILE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
AWAY FROM CORRECTIONS IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
THERE IS NO GUARANTEE THAT THE
CULTURE OF THE DEPARTMENT AND
THE TREATMENT OF YOUTH WILL
CHANGE.
THIS IS A TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY.
BUT ONE THAT REQUIRES A CLEAR
VISION AND COURAGEOUS LEADERSHIP
FROM THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE
PROGRESS FOR YOUTH THEIR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
AS A PART OF THIS EFFORT SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY FOUR IS
ESSENTIAL.
I INCREASING THE COST THE COUNTY
TO PAY WHEN THEY SEND A USED TO
DJJ WHO BASED ON THEIR CHARGES
WAS NOT INTENDED TO BE THERE.
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY FOUR HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO SAVE STATE
COSTS AND TRANSFORM YOUTH LIVES.
IN ADDITION LOCAL SERVICES CAN
BETTER MEET THE NEEDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE AND JUST A FRACTION OF
THE COST.
AND THERE IS MONEY AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDE FOR THE SERVICES.
EACH YEARS COUNTIES RECEIVED
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE CRIME
PREVENTION ACT AND THE YOUTHFUL
OFFENDER BLOCK GRANT.
COUNTIES ARE ALSO BEGINNING TO
RECEIVE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT DIVERSION.
THROUGH A THROUGH THE U. THREE
INVESTMENT GRANT.
AND WITH THE REST AN
INCARCERATION OF YOU THAT THE
LOWEST LEVEL SINCE THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES.
THERE ARE NOT NEARLY NINE
THOUSAND EMPTY BEDS IN LOCAL
FACILITIES.
IN CLOSING WELL THIS IS OF
COURSE AND APPROPRIATIONS
HEARING.
I WANT TO SPEAK TO THE HUMAN AND
NOT JUST THE FINANCIAL COST OF
YOUR DECISION HERE TODAY. ONE OF
OUR WHY DO YOU SEE MEMBERS FROM
LOS ANGELES DION WHITFIELD AND
HIS CELL MATE DERAIL FEASTER
FROM OAKLAND.
RON LOCKED DOWN FOR TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FOUR FOR MONTHS. TWENTY
THREE AND A HALF HOURS A DAY
YEAH ALL MEALS I'M SORRY VIEWS
OF YOUR TWO MINUTES AND IT'S A
COMPELLING STORY -- AND MAYBE
YOU COULD GIVE IT TO US IN
WRITING THAT WE TALK ABOUT THE
FISCAL WE ONLYTALK ABOUT THE
FISCAL.
SO THANK YOU THOUGH I WANT TO
BRING IN ANOTHER STORY I'M SURE
IT IS AN WE'LL BE OKAY MINUTES
THAT'S OKAY.
JUST TRY TO KEEP THIS QUICK --
THEY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
FINANCE IS THAT A SPEAKER OKAY.
VERY BELIEVE BRIEFLY MADAM
CHERILUS BUT THAT'S BEEN US ON
BEHALF OF A COUNTY COALITION THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA THE URBAN COUNTIES
CAUCUS.
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
RESPECTFUL AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO CENTER BILLS
MEASURE WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
THE INCREASE IN THE FEE WILL
RESULT IN ARE DIVERTING MONEY
AWAY FROM THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
INVEST IN LOCALLY THAT ALLOW US
TO KEEP KIDS AT HOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
RG RETIRED CHECK FROM CHRIS
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO MORE FINANCE NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS -- WE HAVE A
MOTION SECOND WE CHECKED CLOSE --
JUST THAT -- SEVENTEEN COUNTIES
HAVE NO USE IN THE IN OUR
FACILITY.
AND NINETEEN COUNTY SERVE.
POPULATIONS OF FIVE OR OR OR OR
FEWER -- SOME COUNTIES HAVE
DEVELOPED THEIR OWN SYSTEMS AND
SEND VERY FEW COUNTIES ORANGE
COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE SINCE ONLY.
NINE PEOPLE TO THE STATE
FACILITY.
THE COUNTY OVER TWO MILLION
PEOPLE.
SO -- ARJUN I'VE -- I THINK THIS
WILL OF FURTHER THE GOAL WE SAID
IN THE BUDGET -- TO TRANSFERRED
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
SERVICES AND I REASONABLE.
THANK YOU ARE YOU.
I SEE A LINE ARE YOU.
WE WERE HOPING TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL.
I'M SORRY WE MISSED YOUR
SUPPORTERS WHEN I'M SHE COME TO
THE IT'S A LITTLE OUT OF
SEQUENCE I'M SORRY BUT WHY DON'T
YOU COME SAY YOUR NAME -- IN
YOUR POSITION -- GOOD MORNING
ISRAEL VIA WITH ME BY SALINAS
ALSO REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LINES FOR YOU THINK COMMUNITY
JUSTICE IN IN STRONG SUPPORT
IMPROPER CO SPONSORS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LARA'S HEALTHY FROM
THE W. HEY WOOD BURNS INSTITUTE
IN SUPPORT.
JAMES MARTINEZ WITH ME TO PUNCH
DRUNK SPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DOWN THE NUMBER THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IN OUR WITH
THE CENTER ON JUVENILE AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING TO ONE SMITH FROM
THE YOU'VE JUST COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THAT WAS ALITTLE OUT
OF ORDER BUT WITH THAT I HEARD A
CLOSE AND THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL CONGRATULATIONS IS
ABOUT.
IF I CAN TAKE BEFORE AS MISTER
MCGUIRE MOVES UP TO THE PODIUM
IF I CAN GET A MOTION ON SB TWO
TO FOUR BY MISS ROW SO MOVED.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY AFRICA
SECOND BY MISCREANT ACT IT'S OUT
ON A ROLL CALL SB FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN BY MONEY.
SECOND I AM MOTION BY MYSTERY ON
A SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK AND
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITHOUT WILL HAVE MISTER MCGUIRE
HE'S -- PRISTINE SB TWENTY SEVEN
IT ENJOYS A DO PASS -- AS
AMENDED.
A MOTION BY MS CARILLO.
SECOND IS SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED HIDING
MADAM CHAIR IN GOOD MORNING --
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BETTER HERE ALL THE STATUS I'M
HAPPY TO GET EXCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AND THEM TO CLARIFY
ALSO SECURITY NUMBERS ON THE TAX
RETURN SHALL BE.
REDACTED THIS BILL ENJOYS
SUPPORT WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THIS
BY THE SECRETARY STATE ALEX
PADILLA -- IN IT WILL ENSURE
THAT FUTURE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES IN CANCER GOVERNOR
WILL BE REQUIRED TO FILE COPIES
OF HIS OR HER.
INCOME TAX RETURNS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SECTOR STATE IN ORDER
TO APPEAR ON THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY BALLOT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE BUT WE
HAVE THE ONE AND ONLY MISS MARK
FROM THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE I'M READY TO GIVE A FIVE
MINUTE TESTIMONY.
KATIE.
WE WORK CLOSE WITH MY STOCK I'M
SURE SHE'LL JUST SAY SH
SUPPORTS ABOUT THEIR EGO. FIFTY
MOCK UP WE HAVE THE SECRETARY
STATE ALEX VIDEO WE SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
SEE NINE AS SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
XENON DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A POSITION
AT THE TIME BUT US SECRETARY
STATE HAS -- ANTICIPATE STUB THE
BILL CURRENTLY IN VERSION WILL
BE MINOR OBSERVABLE WONDERFUL.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WHICH I TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
DON'T THINK SO MUCH RAVENOUS
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL THANK YOU.
MY SENATOR MISTER WEST SO.
YOU'LL BE BREEZING I SP FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS OF THE
INTERACTION BY MISS CARILLO
SECOND IN A SECOND I DON'T WORK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED OKAY.
ARE THESE -- JUST BEFORE FIVE
SEVEN WILL EXTEND THE SUNSET
DATE BY FIVE YEARS FROM
202-122-0264 AN EXISTING
INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO
SUCCESSFULLY OPERATE BY A
METHANE.
PROJECTS THAT INTERCONNECT WITH
GAS UTILITIES PIPELINE SYSTEM --
THIS IS -- A CONTINUATION OF A
BILL.
THAT I AUTHORED LAST YEAR SB
FORTY FORTY WHICH REQUIRES A
CPUC TO ESTABLISH PROCUREMENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR FILE NOTHING.
OF THE TWO PROJECTS. TO PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN AWARDED.
OF US SINCE THE PROGRAM WAS WAS --
STARTED -- THERE'S CURRENTLY
ABOUT THIRTY FOUR MILLION
REMAINING SO WE NEED AN
EXTENSION TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
GET.
MORE PROJECTS -- ON IN IN THE
PIPELINE.
THAT WILL QUALIFY FOR THIS
FUNDING SUCCESSFULLY SO IT IT'S
A MERE ADJUSTMENT TO THE THE THE
END OF THE PROGRAM DATE SO --
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
OKAY SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT.
MORNING I'M HERE NUMBER IS
NEEDED FOR THE COALITION FOR
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS PIPELINE
INTERCONNECTION CALIFORNIA CAN
BE UP TO SIX TIMES AS EXPENSIVE
AS IT IS IN NEIGHBORING STATES.
DO THIS THE INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
FORCED TO CONSTRUCT THE MAJORITY
OF OUR ENERGY PRODUCTION
FACILITIES OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
IRONICALLY MUCH OF THE AREN'T
YOU PRODUCED OUT OF STATE IS
THEN DELIVERED TO CALIFORNIA FOR
USE IN A VARIETY OF IN STATE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS.
THE MONETARY INCENTIVE PROGRAM
WAS CREATED TO HELP COVER THE
COST OF INTERCONNECTION OR TO
EVEN THE PLAYING FIELD FOR IN
STATE PRODUCERS SO THAT THEY CAN
CREATE CLEAN ENERGY JOBS FOR
CALIFORNIA AND THAT SO
CALIFORNIA CAN.
PRODUCE MORE OF THE RG THAT IT
CONSUMES.
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE ONLY MINOR
NEGLIGIBLE COST THE STATE AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WE RESPECT THE
ABSTRACT BUT THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PREY ON BEHALF
OF REPUBLIC SERVICES WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND
DRIVE OUT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS IN IN
OPPOSITION.
FINANCE FINANCE DOESN'T HAVE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME BUT THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION --
ESTIMATES MIGHT AN OBSERVABLE
COSTS.
THANK YOU I SEE NO QUESTIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE US BUT
THAT'S FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU AND IF WE CAN I TAKE A
MOTION ON CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE MOTION BY MISTER BUT LOW AS
SECOND BY MISS CLEO MENTOR
TAKING READ CONSENT COUNTER.
SB ONE SEVENTY THREE TWO FORTY
TWO BY 376-717-01730 FIVE SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
AND SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU
THAT'S ALL GET OUT ON A ROLL
CALL MANSER CHERRY WILL YOU NOW
READ THE BILLS THAT ARE BEING
MOVED AS SUSPENSE FILE.
SB 812-171-4081 515-425-7280
735-436-5412.
FOUR NINETY SEVEN SEVEN FORTY
SIX THANK YOU KNOW IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO ANY OF
THOSE BILLS THAT YOU HEARD MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE BUT WERE
WAVED -- IN PRESENTATION YOU MAY
DO SO NOW.
SEE NOBODY GOING TO THE
MICROPHONE WE ARE COMPLETE WITH
OUR APPROPRIATIONS HEARING --
AND WE WILL CONCLUDE IT